you were right about David the world
breaker Wednesday the power is real you
got to accept it I don't care if you
save me save yourself Commission to
launch the peacemaker you don't have to
be afraid look at you you're God's and
someday you're going to realize you
don't need to listen to it anymore
at the history of the world legion even
Vannelli
when they attend readings the right he
may be the most powerful mutant that we
have ever encountered I'd say that's an
understatement
David Hirsh my job he doesn't seem
fragile no worries me these people's
weakness is also their strength and for
people who are different than human what
does that really like on a sort of
existential level to be telepathic or
telekinetic or the powers that we
explore on the show
three dimensional characters are
essential to good drama and these
characters are literally searching
through the third dimension at the
center of stories this question of power
and who has what capacity
well there's David Haller his ability
seemed to be unknown and unlimited those
who know who Legion is and who he
represents in the Marvel verse get very
excited about because he is this
omega-level mutant if it is not just a
guy who can fly and lifting but a heavy
there's something really cosmic and
crazy going on that I please said who
David meets at the mental hospital in a
world built on abilities and powers and
who we are and figuring our selves out
her aversion to being touched
keeps her always questioning this place
just doesn't seem real maybe it's a
version of reality and not reality
itself she feels like the window for the
audience would need to ask questions
about this world beautiful bill and I
have a shared character Carrie
Loudermilk my Carrie lives inside of his
Carrie she and I are aspects of the same
character - very action based very
strong very physical she's a fighter
because is very mindful he's very smart
he's a scientist
miss putana means played by Jeremy hair
what memories while you keep her busy
his powers memories he remembers
everything in his life and if he's near
you remember everything in yours you go
into your memories look around touch
things feel things ultimately we want to
win this war to allow ourselves the
freedom as in people with powers like
exist comfortably in the world
[Music]
P youtubers is Charlie so a lot of you
requested a legion explainer video for
the last episode in the finale so just
because there's so much going on no base
camp but here we go careful for spoilers
from the latest episode if you haven't
seen it yet if you're new to the channel
and you love comic book stuff be sure to
subscribe to get everything there's
going to be so much happening this
weekend so what I'm going to do is I'll
explain some of the big twist of this
episode what's going on in the comics
and where this is all headed because
there's still a couple big theories that
haven't been disproven we've slowly
started to learn that things are
happening in David's mind in the astral
plane that aren't real that we believed
were real in the past so it's a big mind
trip as to which people are actually
real which people are fake so I'll try
to explain that because I think the show
has given us enough evidence as to what
is real and there are a lot of real
people on this show so I did this in a
top 10 format just to make it easy to
follow number 10 they officially reveal
the villain that Aubrey Plaza has been
playing this whole season Amahl Farouk
the shadow king of the x-men comics so
the really cool thing is the way they
explained him in the episode is very
accurate to his comic book origin story
so number 9 the origin of the shadow
king in the comics the interesting thing
is that the shadow king himself is a
separate entity from a mall Farooq so
Amahl Farouk is just a powerful mutant
from Cairo the shadow king inhabited his
mind the first time we met the shadow
king in the comics is when we met Amahl
Farouk so that's why they're using this
character so the way they explain the
shadow king is that he's this ancient
entity that forms like the dark side of
human psyche since the dawn of humanity
he's just jumped from host to host the
first time we meet him is when he's
inhabiting Amahl Farouk invites
Professor X so they did a version of
that story on the blackboard but the way
they explain it is that Professor X as a
young man was in love with Moira
MacTaggert but he had to go to war he
was injured went to a hospital they went
their separate ways
eventually he finds himself back in
Cairo gets his pocket picked by a young
Aurora Monroe who hasn't become storm
yet but as he's chasing her down to get
his wallet back like this is a professor
EXA can still walk he gets hit by this
psychic blast in its Amahl Farouk so
eventually they fight on the astral
plane he defeats him but then later the
shadow king
essence comes back the way they
explained in the blackboard to inhabit
the mind of Professor X's child
David Haller who debuted in a much later
comic book so they were very true to
that comic book story when they were
doing all these visuals which were
actually very cool I thought it was a
great way to explain this to people that
don't read comics even if you have
missed a couple episodes you could
probably understand the way they explain
it here so here's where it gets really
cool in order to help himself come to
these conclusions
David conjures a mental projection of
himself inside his own mind inside the
sunken place if you haven't seen that
movie to get out this prison that
David's in inside his own mind they kind
of had a version of this going on but
the projection that he's talking to is a
completely separate entity but is
basically himself so he's talking to
himself
even though it manifests as a separate
being he can also do this in the real
world which is why a lot of people have
wondered when they're in the real world
if these other people or faked are they
just mental projection I don't think
that they are and I'll explain why in a
second but number 6 everyone's physical
bodies are trapped inside David's
childhood home frozen in this moment
here with the bullets getting ready to
hit David while all their minds are in
the thrall of the Shadow King inside the
astral plane in this fake version of the
mental hospital so number 5 earlier this
season a lot of people are asking about
the mental hospital there was a real
mental hospital that David was in with
these other characters that was real one
of the biggest pieces of evidence that
lets us know that it's real is because
these other characters outside of David
in the real world when he's not around
talk about it there was a hospital this
is not that hospital right now in this
episode the other reason I don't think
that this is all in David's head like
these people in here are real as they're
trying to escape from the Shadow King is
because of all the effort they expended
on this big action set piece with
glasses that Oliver created they
wouldn't have spent all that time
developing these character arts making
Oliver such a compelling character
making carry and carry compelling
characters and allowing him to go on
this side mission to get Oliver to help
them out is it intended to just pull the
rug out from under us and make them
vanish at the end of the series like oh
they weren't real
none of that stuff matters there will be
some big twists that we might not expect
but I don't think that's going to be one
of them so if you're keeping a list of
things that they want you to think are
real but aren't real it's really just
the second time we go back to the
hospital after the shadow king has taken
over their minds and you see them all
sitting in this ring here number three
we see some of the characters step out
of the mirrors into David's childhood
home and they start to fix the problem
with the bullets you see Oliver start to
conjure that word shield around David if
you couldn't read the words he's
creating a shield around David a
physical shield but all the little words
just read shield the reason that looks
like that is one just to make it look
really badass like oh it's a shield but
it also says shield Oliver is a very
powerful telepath just like David is so
when David saves them all and they get
too you know big bright light that's
when he's pulling them out of the astral
plane back into their physical bodies so
number two they make it back to the
facility you find that Oliver seems like
he's come back to the physical world all
chilling out when the interrogator from
the first episode rolls up with a small
army from level three to take David back
into custody
just as number one the shadow king makes
a crack in David's mental prison so
based on the promo with like the red
ring of light in the creepy way of David
talking makes it sound like the shadow
King will briefly take over his
consciousness in the finale in like the
big action set piece will be him
battling him out of his mind separating
the parasite from him but what about the
big Professor X twist what about x-men
stuff so they've already renewed it for
season two so if they've revealed the
what of David's past but not the who
specifically like they haven't said
Professor X is his father even though
they showed the wheelchair so presumably
push deeper into x-men lore so it's been
an amazing series and I love the way
that they've revealed all this
information the way they basically did a
silent movie when the shadow King was
coming to kill them all like after David
had started to escape his mind he's like
okay fine I'm just going to kill
everybody that was one of the best
moments on television this week I just
totally love what they're doing with
this series and I hope more people find
it before season - but what can happen
later today is there so much Justice
League dropping so once they finish
dropping those teasers I'll put
another Justice League video so that'll
be in a couple hours while you wait for
that to post you can click here for all
the Justice League trailers I've been
posting and you can click here for new
guardians of the galaxy thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you in that next video